oh man  what wait what is it  it looks like you got your hands full is  she wearing  oh lingerie god  that's ballsy yeah that's a word for it  i realized i don't know anything about  you so  what better opportunity to figure out  what you like than to ask for your  opinion on what i should  wear yeah i think you'd look great in  anything you wear but i kind of like the  strapless  okay yeah i like that i mean like she is  literally in broad underwear  at least she has a robe on well i'm  looking forward to seeing you  and that inside likewise i will see you  soon take care  wow damn i  appreciate anybody going out of their  way to make a gesture  you got to love a woman with confidence  walking up in your lingerie  like you own that like i love that you  did that hi friends hi  [Music]  i'm kylie work it please help me choose  a dress here we go  [Music]  you